كان موسم
2003 لرونالدو مع فريق سبورتنج لشبونه هو
ما جعله يتصدر الصفحات في البرتغال حقا
كما بدا اداؤه يشتذب الكثير من الاهتمام
العالمي مع اقتراب نهايه الموسم انتشرت
شائعه انتقاله في جميع ارجاء اوروبا اظهر
ممثلون لليفربول وارسنال وبرشلونه اهتماما
بتوقيع عقد مع المراهق النابغه لكن خلال
مباراه ما قبل الموسم في العام 2003 اثبت
رونالدو حقا انه لاعب مميز
كانت المباراه ضد مانشستر يونايتد
المباراه التي ستغير حياته في شكل جذري
اذا احد اهم التواريخ على الاطلاق في قصه
رونالدو هو السادس من اغسطس عام 2003
عندما تم افتتاح ملعب سبورتنج الجديد ملعب
واستضافوا مباراه وديه ضد مانشستر يونايتد
المباراه الاولى على الاطلاق للاحتفال
بافتتاح الملعب وكان رونالدو قد انضم الى
فريق سبورتنج الاول عند نهايه الموسم
السابق وكانت تلك ساحه جديده مباراه ضد
مانشستر يونايتد وكان مذهلا في تلك
المباراه الوديه ووفق الروايات خلال
الاستراحه بين الشوطين كان اللاعبون
مانشستر يونايتد قد ذهلوا بمناورات هذا
الفتى الذي لا يعرفون عنه اي شيء تقريبا
الى درجه انهم قالوا لمدير مانشستر
يونايتد اليكسون عندما دخلوا غرفه تبديل
الملابس في الاستراحه عليك ان توقع عقدا
مع هذا الفتى واجه مدافع مانشستر يونايتد
المحترف جون اوشيه مصاعب كبيره خلال دقائق
الخمس والاربعين الاولى بسبب اداء رونالدو
الاستثنائي ووفق الروايات ذهب اليكس
فيرجسون الى مدير معدات فريق يونايتد وطلب
منه ان يعثر على بيتر كينيون المدير
التنفيذي للنادي كي يبدا المفاوضات مع
فريق سبورتنج على الفور خلال الشوط الثاني
للحرص على ان يوقع هذا الفتى عقدا مع
مانشستر يونايتد قبل ان يفعل اي نادي اخر
في الواقع كان رونالدو قد حاول التقرب
قليلا من نادي ليفربول حيث قال كم سيكون
سعيدا وكم سيكون مشرفا ان ينضم الى نادي
عريق كهذا كان فريق ارسنال قد التقى بوكيل
رونالدو لكن حرص فيرجس بناء على اقاويل
لاعبيه على التوقيع معه خلال الخمس
والاربعين دقيقه في الشوط الثاني من تلك
المباراه الوديه الى درجه انهم حصلوا على
رونالدو بالفعل مع انطلاق صفاره نهايه
المباراه قال اليكس فيريكسون كريستيانو
اريدك ان تاتي للاعب مع مانشستر يونايتد
وستلعب نسبه 50% من المباريات ذلك اشعرني
بالراحه قلت رائع بالنسبه الي كشاب في
الثامنه عشره المشاركه في 50% من
المباريات هو امر لا يصدق لهذا السبب
اتخذت القرار وساعدني جورج على اتخاذ
القرار بالطبع وكلمات السير اليكسون
الاخيره كانت الاساسيه لموافقه على توقيع
مع مانشستر يونايتد